uh just explain exactly what is going to
be happening this weekend
and of course an awful lot of eyes in
wales will be on that date in august on
which
you could see the country uh moving at
to level zero
okay so from this saturday we're going
to have a number of changes come in to
move to our fully to alert level one
that means that six people can meet up
indoors in private homes and holiday
accommodation
it means that organized indoor events
can take place up to a thousand seated
and 200 standing
and our last and our two ice rinks can
reopen as well although one of them is
still being used as a vaccination center
uh it also means children in groups up
to 30 are going to be able to visit
children's residential centers together
there is though still a specific
requirement uh to have the code risk
assessment
and we still got indoor uh social
distancing
until the seventh of august that's when
we see a more significant change
uh being made without moving to partner
level zero with outdoor events not
having a particular limit
on those as well so it's a significant
step forward and that is because
whilst our case weights are high there
are 140 100 000 lowest in the uk
but lower but still actually quite high
and you'll recall that it wouldn't have
been that long ago case rates of that
number we've been going in reverse
we're not doing that because we've been
really successful in rolling out our
vaccination program
that means that double dose people are
much more protected
and we're not seeing the same level of
harm come into our nhs we've got
73 of adults in wales having had both
doses and that's why
we're looking forward to the 7th of
august when we can release most of the
remaining restrictions and that's when
nightclubs will be able to hear in wales
for example what we are doing though is
we're keeping the requirements for
face coverings to be worn in most public
indoor settings we think that's the
right balance both to prevent
the potential spread of the virus but
also to give people some confidence
we've got lots of
clinically vulnerable people who are
concerned about the pace of movement now
and whether they'll still be protected
and able to enjoy the same freedoms as
well
what needs to happen and did what needs
not to happen between now and august the
seventh at four whales to move to alert
level zero i know that you haven't
described the pro
the process the progress towards that
date is irreversible
no because we've always been cautious
and not wanting to give false hope and
the the idea of absolutes through the
covert pandemic is not something that i
think has been
uh has actually lasted more than a few
weeks so we've always got to look at the
public health position that's both about
case rates and harm coming into our nhs
and also if there's a new variant of
concern circulating as well
because that on a regular point in time
has changed our approach to the pandemic
and how we keep well safe
in wales most people have done a really
good job at all pulling together to keep
whales safe we think that'll continue
the measures we're taking on face
coverings for example is a different set
of
measures being taken to england so
there's a need to make sure that people
understand the rules for the country
they're in
if people are traveling in the uk but
have seen your own piece of course where
there are businesses in england calling
for that greater clarity so
we is a very clear settlement that
people can understand
rules that people can respect it's all
part of us moving together
to try to make sure we don't have to
live with the restrictions we've all had
to
through the first part of the summer and
of course a really really difficult
winter that i certainly don't want to
return to
yep should i i i do wonder then given
given the different advice
be from the devolver administrations in
in wales and and scotland and that from
boris johnson's government are you
concerned about compliance with mask
wearing given that there will be
at different situations in different
parts of the united kingdom
well it's an obvious risk and you've
been talking about confusion in england
this morning
we're asking people to understand the
rules for the part of the united kingdom
they're visiting or taking
undertaking business in we want people
to have a great summer visiting in wales
but to respect the rules are in force
here
as well and actually from the point of
view of the businesses that
are going to need to enforce those rules
i think it's much
easier to give the clarity and the
simplicity that these are rules
it's not a choice that they're opting in
or opting out of there's a requirement
for face going to be worn in a variety
of settings i hope that cloud make it
easier
to avoid the confusion that might
otherwise exist but also for people to
do
the right thing the last moment is
people are arguing about whether they
need to wear a face covering in
a shop sorry sorry to interrupt minister
but does this
does that mean will there be any will
there come a point at which
the welsh administration gives people in
wales
the responsibility for making these
decisions themselves
well there may be a point in time but
it's not going to take place this summer
because we think that the clarity in the
settlement that we've reached for indoor
public spaces is the right balance of
risk
moving forward we're not on a zero risk
position now even with the high levels
of vaccination with an expectation
about the seventh of almost 85 percent
of adults would have had both vaccines
it's about the balance in those risks as
ever the settlement we've reached means
there'll be more economic activity
taking place
more freedoms for people to enjoy and to
enjoy responsibly
and if we all keep on doing the right
thing then we can look forward to
further freedoms and actually not going
backwards
to the position we've had to live
through earlier on this year
but i just don't think it's helpful to
try to forecast a point in time at which
we may not need to wear face coverings
we're really looking to get to the end
of this pandemic and to see a recovery
undertaken that isn't going to be set
back if we need to reimpose restrictions
in the future